f Medes hunkered down praying for his
life after an airstrike nearly killed
him while filming for Sky News his
cameras been destroyed he films on his
phone as the fighting continues around
him
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in a lull he takes his chances to run
somewhere safer it is thought to be
footage of the air strike a little
earlier that nearly killed Ahmed but did
take the lives of two Turkish soldiers
[Music]
on skype he told us he was certain it
had been a Russian war it matters a lot
because this is potentially a major
escalation if a NATO member countries
troops have been attacked and killed
directly by Russia
and it highlights the dangers ahead as
turkey continues sending its forces deep
into Italy and Russia continues blocking
any efforts at the UN towards a
ceasefire
I think it's cynical of the Russians I
think it shows the lack of humanity they
will have seen the same footage in the
same scenes that you've shown your
viewers and yet they don't want to do
anything to try and protect civilians
hundreds of thousands of people are now
cornered in camps and pressed up against
the Turkish border as the Assad regime
closes in in a war that targets
civilians they're not just asking for
tents and blankets they're asking for
safety this is not a war in which
civilians are simply being caught
between two different armies this is a
war in which the civilians themselves
are under attack it's in a war on an
entire population it's a war on children
the world has wrung its hands apparently
impotent to stop serious carnage for
almost a decade but over this border is
a killing zone where millions are now
trapped at this 11th hour will it now
act Dominik Waghorn sky news on Turkey's
border with Syria